foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday November 18th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
the collapse of FTX has caused pain for
customers and the crypto sector at large
it was also a massive blow for ftx's
roughly 300 employees many of whom held
a stake in the company or owned its
in-house cryptocurrency ftt The Wall
Street Journal spoke with more than a
dozen current and former employees many
of whom said they were stunned by ftx's
Swift demise and shocked by the alleged
misuse of customer funds by its founder
Sam bankman freed joining us to discuss
where this all leaves ftx's workers is
our reporter Alexander osipovic hi Alex
thanks for joining me thanks for having
me so you spoke with FTX staff what was
it like for them at the company before
the collapse it was a pretty good place
to work that they got paid well they
thought that they were part of this
idealistic Enterprise because Sam
bankman freed was so associated with
philanthropy and the movement called
effective altruism he pledged to give
one percent of the exchanges fee Revenue
to charity so these uh people thought
that they were doing good working at a
fast-growing company that was going to
change the world obviously things didn't
work out so great for the company but
how did employees of FTX find out about
the collapse and the allegations of
misuse of customer funds that have been
made the employees were basically
blindsided by everything that went down
on very very few of them seem to have
known about the misuse of customer funds
it appears the knowledge of that was
kept tightly within a small circle of
Executives the founders around Sam
makeman freed all the other employees
I've talked to said they didn't suspect
anything so they were utterly shocked
they basically found out that it was
happening the same time we and the
public did through tweets and media
reports and things like that and one of
the big complaints that the employees
had last week as FTX was trying to sell
itself and things like that they weren't
hearing anything from management Sam
came in with some belated updates over
the company slack Channel but they were
very frustrated they weren't hearing
anything sooner and can you tell us what
their reactions were as they did find
out about the collapse and some of the
actions that were taken by Sam bankman
freed and other Executives we have
sources who told us that one FTX
executive Ryan salami actually threw up
when he learned about the misuse of
customer funds uh because it was such a
shock to him there are other employees
who quit in fact I would say many
perhaps most of the staff quit over the
space of a few days they didn't want to
be associated with the FTX anymore
they've submitted their resignations uh
sort of a rush for the exits and many
people sent Sam angry messages or
expressed their discontent over chats or
even over Twitter in one case the
Fallout though for these workers it goes
beyond losing their job doesn't it
weren't a lot of them investors in FTX
as well yes this was a financially
ruinous for a lot of these employees
many of them had taken the opportunity
to buy FTX Equity there are different
opportunities of doing that and
sometimes they got it as bonuses and all
that Equity was wiped out in the
bankruptcy in addition to that some of
them actually were big holders of the
ftt token which is a cryptocurrency
created by FTX itself that has almost
completely collapsed in value during all
these events and lastly many of the
international employees actually were
paid by direct deposits to FTX so
instead of getting direct deposited to
the bank they got paid by deposits to
The Exchange ftx.com and so when ftx.com
froze to its customers the employees
also couldn't withdraw their money and
FTX has its headquarters in the Bahamas
is this the case both for the expats who
were working there and for the bahamians
who were employed by FTX as well well
the uh collapse of FTX had somewhat
different impacts on The Expatriate
employees in the Bahamas and the local
hires
the local hires were excited about this
new industry that was coming to their
Island and some of them you spent
thousands of dollars to buy FTX Equity
but generally they weren't in senior
roles they were in sort of logistics
compliance in some cases and they were
of course very disappointed by the
events that happened in the case of The
Expatriate employees these are usually
people who are fairly well off or
successful in their own right and they
essentially responded by leaving the
island some of them had trouble as they
were leaving for instance they had FTX
credit cards and the credit cards in
some cases were declined as they were
trying to fly out of the Bahamas to go
back to New York or Hong Kong or other
places you know a lot of customers
really put a ton of faith and trust in
Sam bankman freed he was seen as this
sort of good voice for the crypto
industry before this all happened what
was his reputation like inside the
company and you know Howard employees
feeling about that changing now so I
would say inside the company generally
people believe that he was a good guy
the sort of myth that you've seen about
him outside was true inside the company
they thought that he was driven by
ethics and philanthropy and he and his
sort of inner circle talked a lot about
effective altruism and maximizing the
value of the things that they were doing
there were some kind of quirks that I
think weren't really apparent to the
outside uh he wasn't always the best
manager he ran a very flat organization
and so as FTX grew he became kind of
this bottleneck and everybody needed to
get Sam's approval to do anything and
sometimes he was kind of unresponsive
and there was also
um I think some resentment of some of
the inner circle around him as having
too much power but on the whole I think
that people were generally pretty happy
to work there so what's the future then
for workers who have left FTX and for
those who've stayed with the company my
understanding is not that many people
have stayed with FTX there are a small
number of people who are helping to wind
down the business and help the new
leadership of the company that was put
in charge after the bankruptcy
proceedings began the people who have
left I think will have something of a
challenge because their refutations have
been tarnished even if they knew nothing
about the misuse of customer funds they
feel like they now have this big toxic
patch on their resume they're also
worried about potentially being targeted
in lawsuits and investigations and
things like that and are fearing that
that might consume their lives for the
next few years at least all right that
was our reporter Alexander ossipovic
thanks so much for joining us Alex
thanks very much for having me
and that's it for Tech news briefing
this week our producer is Julie Chang
our supervising producer is Chris
zinsley and I'm your host Zoe Thomas
thanks for listening and have a great
weekend
[Music]
[Music]